world leader mcconnell moved to table
his own bill
so republicans could then vote against
tabling it
that's what the republican majority
thinks passes for a serious attempt
at covet relief bill in this republican
senate
when people are suffering so badly games
games
when people are suffering the truth is
the republican leader needed that vote
to fail
because if the senate actually proceeded
to a real bill
it might mess up the timing of the
republican plan
to confirm judge barrett to the supreme
court
now think of that for a moment the
republican majority sets up a fake vote
on covert relief because if god forbid
the senate actually considered a real
bill to do something real about this
overwhelming covet crisis
it might delay their supreme court
nominee that they are rushing through
in an oppressed process that can only be
declared as abusive to the senate
that's all the american people need to
know about priorities on the other side
of the aisle
russia nominee through whose views are
way to the right of the american people
and ignore avoid play games
with getting covert relief which is the
number one thing the american people
want
not a supreme court nominee
who is so far away from their views
while the country is hurting while
millions of americans are sick and dying
while workers lose their jobs businesses
close their doors
republican senators are playing
political stunts
with vitally needed economic relief
and the games continue today once again
the republican majority will bring up a
bill designed to fail
their partisan emaciated
coveted relief bill so-called coveted
relief bill
the bill we're voting on today has
already failed in the senate
didn't get a democratic vote and we
already know it lacks the votes
and why because it leaves so many
americans behind
renters and homeowners are left behind
there's no relief for them
americans who've lost jobs through no
fault of their own are left behind
americans who rely critical on critical
public service by their
state and local governments are left
behind
small businesses in communities of color
and in some of the hardest hit
industries our restaurants our concert
venues theaters non-profits
local news received no
no dedicated assistance the republican
pro
proposal on covid doesn't even devote
enough resources to testing and tracing
despite a spike in cases
and the harrowing prospect of a second
wave of the virus sweeping across
america
it's laden with poison pills that our
republican colleagues know
democrats would never support that's not
a real attempt to legislate and get
something done
what's in there a giant corporate
immunity provision to shield
corporations from liability if they put
their workers in dangerous covet related
situations
tax provision to benefit wealthy
families who send their kids to private
schools
while shortchanging middle class
families in public schools
there's no reason for a republican's
colleagues to insist on a corporate
liability
shield and a provision to injure public
schools in a coveted relief bill
no reason they know it's objectionable
they know it's partisan
they know it's an anchor around the
minimal bill they have enough to sink it
there's no reason to include these
poison pills and legislation
that they know needs bipartisan support
to pass
because 20 republicans have said they
don't want to vote for any money
so they know they need democrats but
they put things in the bill that they
know democrats will oppose
and lead to the bill's demise
this minimal bill
so what's the logic here well there is a
perverse logic
if the republican leader wants to make
sure that the bill fails
and that's sure what it looks like it's
clear why leader mcconnell is forced to
do these stunts
a good portion of his caucus opposes
more relief to the american people
yesterday the republican whip the member
in charge of counting republican votes
said quote i think we're going to have a
hard time finding
13 republican votes for anything 13.
out of 52 53.
one republican member proudly vowed
quote
not to vote for another dime
people are being kicked out of their
homes
children are starving there's no testing
and tracing that meets the needs
schools can't open and not another
dime let america suffer
so our right wing ideology
saying that we shouldn't make well-to-do
people pay taxes that's what their last
tax cut bill did
can prevail over the needs of america
and the american people so it's not
democrats who are blocking a real relief
bill we know that
everyone knows that speaker pelosi is
still trying her best with the white
house to get a deal
we've already offered to meet
republicans halfway
the biggest obstacle to another relief
bill from the very beginning has been
senate republicans and leader mcconnell
and as if we needed any more proof it
was pretty obvious before
it was reported in multiple news outlets
confirmed by four senators who were at
the meeting that leader mcconnell
warned the white house against making
another deal on another stimulus bill
before the election
let me repeat that leader mcconnell
while he was coming to the floor and
railing against democratic obstruction
was behind the scenes warning the white
house against striking a bipartisan deal
on covet relief who does he think he can
fool not the american people
ask them they know who's to blame they
know democrats and
up and down the line are for relief
and republicans are opposing it and i'll
tell you one thing
the american people are sick and tired
of these political stunts
they're sick and tired of politicians
who would rather have it appear that
they are working
than do actual work this shouldn't be so
hard we all know how to pass bills in
the senate with bipartisan buy-in and
bipartisan support
we did it in the cares bill back in
march
but ever since that bill passed this
senate republican majority has gone
totally partisan
every step of the way even on an issue
as important to the country as relief
from this evil pandemic
now on the supreme court the republican
leader has announced that the senate
will vote on judge amy coney barrett to
be the supreme court to be a supreme
court justice next monday
tapping what will be the most rushed
most partisan and least legitimate
process
in the history the entire history of
supreme court nominations
leader mcconnell continues to defile the
senate
more than any other senator has done in
a very long time
let us hope that leader mcconnell hasn't
ruined the senate for good
with this nasty 180 degree turn
holding up merrick garland and rushing
this judge through while people are
online at the polling places
the idea let's wait for the next
election
was total hypocrisy total
hypocrisy the united states senate has
never
never considered a supreme court justice
this close to a national presidential
election
i doubt it ever will again i don't think
we'll ever have the combination of
donald trump and leader mcconnell
who so don't care about what they said
in the past
mcconnell anyway who so don't care about
trying to pick
a justice who will look at the law
as opposed to ideological views
hope so hope it doesn't happen again
pray it doesn't happen again just four
years ago we all know the republican
leader
the former chairman of the judiciary
committee the current chairman of the
judiciary committee
and nearly every single republican
member argued that president obama's
nominee
didn't deserve a hearing or a vote on
the floor of the senate
because there was a national election
eight months away
mere hours after the passing of justice
scalia leader mcconnell said the
american people deserve a voice in the
selection
of their next supreme court justice not
if one party or another party controlled
the presidency or the senate
absolute the american people deserve a
voice
that was eight months from an election
leader mcconnell confirmed yesterday
that the vote to confirm president
trump's nominee to the supreme court
will take
place eight days before an election
senate republicans could wait eight
months
to give the american people a voice in
selecting a supreme court justice now
they can't wait eight days
i am sure that if they had to the
republican majority would confirm a
supreme court justice eight minutes
before election day
is it no wonder that democrats are so
angry is it no wonder that the american
people are
tearing their hair out when they have
said
they want to wait till the next election
when that's only fair
that's only democratic small d
the hypocrisy is towering and enormous
and as i said leader mcconnell could
destroy this chamber
for a very long time
why is this happening well this is part
of a decade-long
effort to shift the courts to the far
right
so that the far right which has this so
many republicans in their grasp
can accomplish through the judiciary
what they could never accomplish through
the congress
senate republicans failed to repeal the
affordable care act we know that
happened right here
so president trump and republicans
attorney general are suing to eliminate
the law on court
senate republicans don't dare put repeal
of roe v wade on the floor of the senate
they know it would fail
but they try to appoint justices who are
who are dedicated to repealing that
vital right
of a woman to choose and to control her
own body
this is just an amazing moment
one of coney barrett's very first cases
would be to hear arguments against the
affordable care act the very act that
this chamber
rejected repeal of
republicans as i said could never repeal
a woman's right to choose in congress
they don't even dare bring it to the
floor
the far-right has never had a majority
on the court to limit roe
or griswold but if judge barrett becomes
justice barrett it very well might
women of america watch out watch out
i'll remind my colleagues and the
american people
when president trump was asked about roe
v wade during his final debate against
hillary clinton he said quote
if we put another two or three justices
on the court the repeal of roe v
wade will happen automatically is that
what this republican
majority stands for if they do announce
it to the american people
don't hide behind this idea
that justices are calling balls and
strikes
that they will obey precedent
don't hide behind that because we know
what's happening here
the american people should make no
mistake their fundamental rights are on
the line
the right to affordable health care to
make their own medical decisions to join
a union vote without impediments the
right to marry who they love
that's what this is all about
now leader mcconnell has strained
credulity to argue that ramming a
supreme court justice through the senate
while american voters wait in line to
cast their ballots as completely normal
nothing to see here he says who believes
him i don't think a single republican on
that side believes him
but they know what's going on this is
not the senate as he says performing its
historic function
it's a fiction there is no precedent in
history for the senate
for what the republicans are doing
abraham lincoln
our great hero great republican rejected
nominating somebody for the supreme
court so close to an election
so republicans at the very least or to
go on record and admit
this is an extraordinary breach of
precedent of comity of fairness
of decency of honor of truth of
consistency
so in a short time i will make a point
of order
that the senate should not consider a
nomination to the supreme court
this close to a presidential election
every senator will vote on whether a
nomination this close to an election
shall be in order
it will confirm to the american people
what we all know to be true
that the republican majority has
absolutely no intention of honoring the
supposed principle
it's so vehemently argued in 2016
that they won't follow history that they
won't follow precedent that they won't
follow norms and traditions of the
senate
that they won't even follow their own
standards
that is the indelible mark on this
senate majority
that here in leader mcconnell's senate
it's the rule of
because we can might makes right
because we can as senator whitehouse put
it
all to confirm a far-right justice on
the court would rip away health care
from tens of millions of americans
in the middle of a pandemic we'll see
how my republican colleagues vote
i yield the floor
mr president senator from south dakota
mr president for
months now democrat leaders have held
additional covet relief
hostage instead of working with
republicans to arrive at a compromise
bill
that both parties can support and they
can make it through both houses of
congress democrats have insisted
that it's their way or the highway
either republicans agree to a bloated
multi-trillion dollar piece of
legislation filled with
non-coronavirus related measures
and far left liberal wish list
items a bill that would never make it
through both houses of congress
or americans get no relief that's
basically the
choice the democrats have left the
american people
this president goes without saying that
this is not the attitude of a party that
really wants to get help to americans
this is the attitude
of a party that wants to use this crisis
for political purposes
democrats figure that they win either
way either they
use this crisis to force through a bunch
of liberal priorities not related to
covet or they blame republicans for the
lack of a bill
completely absent from their
calculations as any sense of what their
intransigence is costing
the american people if democrats had
actually been willing to compromise with
republicans to reach consensus-led
consensus legislation
we could have had a new covert relief
bill months ago
americans could be enjoying additional
relief right now
republicans have made it clear since the
summer that we were willing to
compromise with democrats on a new bill
all we asked was the democrats come to
the aisle
i should say come to the table with a
reasonable proposal that could actually
make
it through both houses of congress
but democrats haven't been interested
oh sure speaker pelosi has supposedly
been working on an agreement with the
white house
four months we constantly hear from the
speaker that a deal is getting closer
only to discover the next day
that a deal isn't really close at all
mr president let me tell you something
if you are the speaker of the house and
you really want to arrive at a
compromise
it doesn't take you three months it
probably even doesn't take you three
weeks
this president democrats have to know
very well that there is no way
for them to get a bill containing
everything they want through both houses
of congress
but democrats could get some of what
they want
and isn't something better than nothing
even if democrats were right about the
need for every penny of spending that
they're calling for wouldn't it be
better to get
some of that spending passed than to
have nothing
to democrats apparently the answer is no
mr president just a few minutes the
senate will be voting on republican
coronavirus legislation
our bill would provide more money for
the hardest hit small businesses
more health care resources to fight the
virus and money to help schools reopen
and operate safely
priorities that all of us democrats and
republicans should be able to agree on
in theory i'm pretty sure we do agree
on them yet all signs suggest that
democrats will filibuster this
coronavirus relief legislation
for the second time even though
passing this bill would get more money
into the hands of small businesses
and schools even though this bill would
provide additional funding for covent
testing
and treatment nevertheless once again
democrats will choose
nothing nothing over something
once again democrats will decide that if
they can't get everything they want it's
better for americans
not to have anything mr president i hope
whatever perceived political gains
democrats are getting from their refusal
to
negotiate are worth denying help to the
american
people in a few minutes republicans will
cast their votes in favor
of covet relief and i invite
rank and file democrat to reject their
leaders obstruction
and join us on that vote mr president i
yield the floor
mr president senator from illinois mr
president
late last night the news flash was
senator mcconnell republican leader of
the united states senate
opposes covet 19 relief bill and informs
the white house
supposedly it was a statement made by
senator mcconnell at his republican
lunch yesterday
and it was later confirmed by four
republican senators who attend
who attended that that is what occurred
finally it becomes public one of the
things that has been
suspected for a long time on this side
of the aisle
you see most of us have been paying
close attention to these speeches by
senator mcconnell to try to
gauge his interest in really coming back
to help the american people
we remember on march 26 when 96 to
nothing 96 to nothing the senate voted
for coburn relief in what was known as
the cares act
it was a bipartisan measure responding
to a national pandemic that was just
starting to surface
in an economy that was just starting to
collapse
many people thought at the time that
that would be the end of our
journey that we would do what's
necessary and put it behind us
and so the unemployment assistance for
example ended on july 31st of this year
the ppp the paycheck protection program
ended
in the middle of august we were wrong
the pandemic got dramatically worse
and the economy slumped even further
millions more were out of work
thousands were dying more were infected
and we still are in a terrible battle
now
against this deadly virus so the
obvious solution was for congress to
come back
and to help again the first measure was
good
and i think helpful but it wasn't enough
we needed more so nancy pelosi the
democratic speaker of the house
five months ago five months ago in may
passed a coveted relief bill to follow
on from the original bill
she sent it over to senator mcconnell
five months ago
and he did nothing what he said was
i want to see if i feel a sense of
urgency
about the need for this bill a sense of
urgency
well today 220 000 americans have died
americans are dying at a pace from this
coronavirus
that is unimaginable do you understand
that the death rate from covid in
america
is two and a half times the death rate
in canada do we realize that the
infection rate from cova 19 in the
united states
is five times what it is in canada or
germany
do we understand that with four and a
half percent of the world's population
the united states sadly leads the way in
covet 19 deaths with 20
of all of the people who've died on
earth from covet 19 from the united
states of america
the efforts to deal with coven 19 have
failed
and the american people know it they're
tired of this
way of living with these masks but they
know if they don't
they risk their health and the safety of
others
they want this economy to come back to
life they want the kids to go back to
school
but we can't move forward unless we have
leadership number one and that's what an
election is all about
a plan number two and the resources to
implement it
what are the resources that senator
mcconnell believes are necessary to deal
with this
when it comes to testing 16 billion
dollars
for the nation 16 billion dollars we are
currently testing a million people a day
across the united states we should be
testing 14 million people a day
if we're serious about contact tracing
if we're serious about reopening the
economy
and so the senator from kentucky comes
to the floor this morning
and talks about the obstructionism of
nancy pelosi
obstructionism five months ago she
passed a coveted relief bill and sent it
to his desk
and he never once brought it for the to
the floor for a debate or a vote not
once
he mocks it criticizes it day after day
after day
but he's afraid of a vote on the floor
of the united states senate
so he comes up with an elaborate
procedural scheme which we'll see in
just a few minutes here
that basically wants to put together
his package for coven relief
but his package is missing so many key
elements that we know it will not
respond to this national crisis
it's the old story of a man 30 feet from
shore
drowning and someone stands by the shore
and tosses him a 5 foot rope
it doesn't work it doesn't reach it
doesn't save him
the chairman of the federal reserve
jerome paulus told us
that if we don't do something there will
be a tragic result with the american
economy
if we pass a bill of the magnitude
suggested by speaker pelosi
we have a chance of recovering by the
end of 2021.
if we don't the chairman of the federal
reserve
warns us and other economists as well
that we're going to slump
into an even worse recession even more
unemployment
even more business is failing that
appears to be
what senator mcconnell is prepared to
accept but we're not
those of us who were sent here to deal
with the real problems and challenges
for americans
realize we need more than just a an
effort
that throws that five-foot rope to a man
drowning 30 feet from shore
that is the mcconnell approach as we
take a look at the elements that are
missing
in the mcconnell approach they are
lengthy
virtually every state and local
government in the nation
has seen a downturn in revenue because
the economy contracting
we want to help these state and local
governments
survive to be able to ignore
or i should say overcome
the need to lay off health care workers
and teachers and firefighters and police
that's what we believe in and that's
what we include in our bill
not in the mcconnell bill housing
no funding for housing or rental
assistance
in the mcconnell bill that will be
brought before us economic stimulus
remember the 1200
checks there are no direct stimulus
checks
in the mcconnell proposal he says that
we are holding out to help the coastal
elites news flash
senator mcconnell the coastal elites
don't qualify
for these checks nor should they
ordinary people do
and your bill doesn't help them on
unemployment senator mcconnell's bill
cuts the benefits in half the federal
benefits
for unemployment and then he puts in
this provision
incredible provision that gives large
companies immunity from liability
if they do not take the necessary steps
to protect their employees and customers
that's a high priority the big shots do
pretty well in senator mcconnell's bill
when it comes to testing senator
mcconnell is prepared to spend 16
billion as i mentioned earlier
the bill that we support has over 57
billion dollars
for hospitals and health care clinics
and 75 billion for testing
nutrition senator mcconnell says we're
just trying to
help the blue state billionaires well
i've got news for him
they don't qualify for snap benefits and
there's no snap benefit
increase in the mcconnell bill we
believe there should be
people are standing in line at food
banks america can do better
money to help the schools we put more
money into that than senator mcconnell
does
help for the postal service which has
been hard-pressed
by the current state of the economy
we also have paycheck protection program
which we all agree
needs to be there for the small
businesses i will just conclude by
saying this
we have our chance now to work together
on a bipartisan basis
to help people who are counting on us
senator mcconnell's approach has to be
rejected
it is just a an effort to find some
cover politically so people can go home
and say well i voted for something
let's do something that makes a
difference in the lives of people and
helps them
let's deal with this coronavirus
directly and let's help those who are
suffering with job loss
and struggling to make ends meet get
through this crisis themselves
that is the responsibility that we face
and it's one that i think we should face
honestly
i listened as my friend and colleague
senator thune came
and said that we were holding america
hostage
with our position on the democratic side
we're not holding them hostage
it was senator mcconnell who refused to
participate in the negotiations and
still does
we have an effort bipartisan effort
between the white house
and speaker pelosi to solve this problem
and to come together again as we did in
march
it is time for us to do it the president
may say he's tired of covid
but america can't be tired of coven we
have to face it every single day and
fight it every day the senate and
congress should help
i yield the floor senator from vermont
mr president i
i concur with everything our
distinguished
assistant leader has said mr president
we're in the middle of the most
devastating public health crises in
modern history
the american people are paying a
terrible price
nearly 220 000 americans have died in
just 10 months
put that in perspective that
significantly more than the number of
americans who died in the korean the
vietnam
the iraq and the afghanistan wars
combined all of them remember when
president trump
trump called himself a war president
president trump said he's a war
president well as he acted like one no
he called the virus a hoax he's been
awol ever since millions have lost their
jobs
they're struggling to make ends meet
people are being evicted from their
homes they're living in their cars
in shelters or on the streets they're
relying on the generosity of others
and the virus is still not remotely
under control
the need for another comprehensive
emergency funding bill to address the
covert crisis is obvious
it's urgent has been for five months and
what the senate doing
staging show votes and covert relief
bills
that the majority leader himself has
said we'll go nowhere
and then they go back on their word but
both the majority leader and the
chairman of the judiciary
committee said a year ago as they try to
rush through the nomination of a supreme
court justice
less than two weeks before the election
after millions of americans
have already voted so what are their
priorities i know where mine are
they're with the families of the 220
000 americans who've lost their lives to
this virus
they're with the thousands of vermonters
the millions more across the nation have
lost their jobs during this pandemic
there were the small business owners
trying to stay afloat during this crisis
there were the fathers and mothers who
wonder if they'll be able to pay
next month's rent or put food on the
table they're with the children
struggling to learn to zoom calls in
online classes
so it's a national disaster and it
requires real solutions
we need a comprehensive bill to address
this problem
we can't do it with fig lease or do a
piece bill senator mcconnell wants to do
we can't
pass an inadequate bill today or the
chance
maybe we'll come back later and do what
we should have done
to begin with that's not how it works
everyone knows that we have one chance
and what remains of this year to get it
right we owe it to the american people
everybody i don't care whether they're
republicans democrats independence to
everybody
to try the majority leader staged a show
yesterday
he didn't bring up a comprehensive
proposal for covert relief
over there for debate he called for a
process voted only one part of it
the paycheck protection program why i
support that program we all do
it's been critical in keeping literally
thousands of vermont small businesses
afloat
but take a look at this proposal it
falls flat
it ignores critical improvements of the
program that would be made by
considering the heroes act
expanding access to all non-profits
making critical access
hospitals eligible for ppp addressing
arbitrary caps on various loan programs
to help small businesses more
importantly
providing more funding for this program
if nothing else wouldn't even remotely
solve the problems facing our country
the economy won't come back until the
american people have confidence the
virus has been vanquished
we need more funding for the ppp program
we all agree on that but we need to fix
that program and do so much more
we have to invest more in testing it
needs to be based on national testing
and contact training
tracing strategy so we can quickly
identify cases isolate those who've been
exposed
how many times you have to say this we
need to develop a vaccine distribution
program now so it can be up and running
as soon as the vaccine is available we
have to provide personal protective
equipment
to those on the front lines we have to
ensure our hospitals
have their resources uh they need to
take care of the bill we need to keep
our nursing homes safe and virus free
so if you do just a target bill aimed at
one sec sector that's a way to avoid
doing what's really needed
and it picks winners and losers at a
time when everyone is struggling
no matter how much aid we give to small
business or the airlines or to our
struggling restaurant industry
our economy doesn't come back to the
virus is under control so we need a
comprehensive bill
not the so-called mcconnell skinny bill
we're voting on today
buys only 500 billion dollars of covert
relief
less than half of even what the trump
administration
proposed just a month ago look at the
lines of food banks they've skyrocketed
during this crisis but there's nothing
in this bill for nutrition assistance
look at the millions of americans who
are struggling to pay next month's
renter keep up with their mortgage
payment
notwithstanding the wishful thinking of
the president
this is a massive problem and either the
president doesn't know it
or he doesn't care maybe it's both 25
million americans
unemployment compared to just 2 million
at the end of january
and the unemployment assistance in this
bill is totally inadequate nothing
in the bill for state and local
governments are on the front line
fighting this virus inadequate money for
testing and education
child care no funding for community
health centers
no funding to fight this on a global
level so we're not going to defeat this
pandemic if we ignore what's happening
outside the united states
americans can't safely resume
international travel
commerce i mean i could go on there's so
much
that's missing it's about what do they
put in oh
they turn something over to the
well-paid lobbyists
of corporations by providing
sweeping liability shields for corporate
wrongdoers
who have failed to do their part to keep
employers
and consumers and patients safe
that tells you everything you need to
know about what's in it
a special earmark for big corporations
so they can come ahead of a struggling
american family
we know it's not going to pass it
shouldn't pass
let's start working and getting
something that can be passed as senator
durbin said
the house passed a hero's bill over five
months ago
and they passed it again three weeks ago
why don't we take it up
vote it up or vote it down let's ask the
votes let's put
make people stand up and say what are
they really
really for
if we don't then democracies failed the
american people
failed i see my colleague on the floor i
didn't realize
he was there before so i will put the
rest of my statement on the record and
yield the floor
that objective hey mr president the
senator from north carolina
thank you mr president i ask unanimous
consent that i'd be allowed to finish my
comments before the vote
is objection without objection thank you
mr president i rise today again to speak
on behalf of the brave and hardworking
men and women of law enforcement across
this nation
last month i talked about the dangerous
consequences of inaction by the senate
if we didn't come to protect them and
unfortunately
since my last speech four more law
enforcement officers men and women have
died
been murdered in the line of duty that's
a 20
increase over the same number this time
last year and that doesn't count the
hundreds of police officers who have
been injured in the line of duty
many of them still recovering from their
wounds the groundswell of violence
against law enforcement is shocking and
it's our responsibility as senators to
act
enough is enough rather than support
radical ideas like defunding
and abolishing the police the senate
should take the lead and pass
meaningful legislation to protect law
enforcement officers
increasing funding improving training
and raising standards
that's why again calling my colleagues
to support and pass the protect and
serve act
a bill that i've sponsored and a bill
that i hope we can get past
the protect and serve act would punish
dangerous criminals
who murder a law enforcement officer in
the line of duty
if they murder a law enforcement officer
in the line of duty they'll be sentenced
to life
if they injure a law enforcement officer
in the line of duty
they'll be sentenced to 10 years in
prison the premise of the legislation is
simple
there's no escape from justice for
dangerous criminals who intentionally
assault or kill a law enforcement
officer
the senate passed the senate passes
legislation almost every day in this
chamber by unanimous consent
but i'm sad to report that if i try to
get unanimous consent for this bill that
we would have objection on the floor
the heated rhetoric and the violent
attacks officers are having
on officers are having real world
impacts
and the safety of law enforcement has
never been at the low that it is today
across the country recruitments are down
fewer people are applying to go into
service account or into law enforcement
academies
and retirements are up we're seeing our
law enforcement ranks
dwindle it's sad but it's not surprising
law enforcement officers put their lives
on the line every single day
every morning they wake up they kiss
their spouse goodbye
and they don't know if they're going to
come back safely
but when they spend all day being
disrespected doing this very difficult
and very dangerous job
and politicians harass them or allow
them to be harassed i should say
by violent mobs protesters
there's no wonder that morale's at an
all-time low
fewer police means more criminal
activity
it means hard-working american senator
citizens who are going to work every day
just to make their lives
better are living in communities that
are less safe
we cannot sit idly by and allow for the
streets to be filled with dangerous
violent criminals who face no
consequences
instead we must speak up and show our
men and women in blue
that we respect them and we back them
they put their lives on the lives to
protect us
and we should do the work in congress to
protect them
in fact in the last congress speaker
pelosi allowed this bill
to be voted on she supported making it a
law
but now her conference is run by radical
leftists who want to abolish the police
or defund the police
and she's not even allowing this bill to
be brought to the floor
she won't speak in support of law
enforcement officers despite the rising
tide of violence against them
that's why the responsibility lies here
in the senate
for us to show our support and let law
enforcement communities across the
country know that we have their backs
let's protect police deputies and let's
pass the protect and serve act
i urge the american people to call your
senators and tell them that you want
this bill passed
you want law enforcement to be safer and
you want our communities to be safer
don't be silent help me fight for the
men and women in blue
they're counting on all of us thank you
mr president
to invoke cloture cloture motion
we the undersigned senators in
accordance with the provisions of rule
22 of the standing rules of the senate
to hereby move to bring to a close
debate on the motion to concur
in the house amendment to s-178 an act
to condemn gross
human rights violations and so forth
with a further amendment number 2652
signed by 17 senators
by unanimous consent the mandatory
quorum call has been waived
the question is is it the sense of the
senate that debate on the motion to
concur in the house amendment
with amendment number 2652
to s-178 an act to condemn gross human
rights violations of ethnic turkic
muslims to zhang jing
and calling for an end to arbitrary
detention torture and harassment of
these communities
inside and outside
you